phoenix persönlich egon ramms war einer
der höchsten nato generäle und wir
treffen ihnen heute am rolandsbogen bei
bonn herzlich willkommen so für nichts
persönlich heran herzlichen dank für die
einladung ich bin gerne bei ihm wir
freuen uns heran lassen sie uns zuerst
einen blick auf die aktuelle lage werfen
die ukraine krieg es wurden ja mehrfach
feuerpausen und rückzugs bewegungen
verkündet aber selten eingehalten
wie beurteilen sie die aktuelle lage
die aktuelle situation in der ukraine
zeigt dass die russische seite die
erfolge die man erringen wollte bisher
nicht errungen hat es hat sich in den
letzten vier wochen fünf wochen die
situation ergeben dass die russen
versucht haben weiter vorzudringen
dieses hauptsächlich gemacht haben in
denen die größere städte angegriffen
haben was dann mächtig zu lasten der
zivilbevölkerung geht auch sicherlich
viele tote und viele verwundete
verursacht hat die ukrainische
streitkräfte sind zurzeit sehr stark was
ihre kampfkraft und ihre moral angeht
haben die wir gehört haben ja auch in
kiew statt bereiche die bereits zu den
händen der russen waren wieder
zurückerobert
es gibt dieses große gerücht seit
gestern dass die russen sich
zurückziehen würden im norden diesem
gericht glaube ich nicht das war glaube
ich aus dem grunde nicht weil wir
ähnliche situationen schon gehabt haben
bevor der krieg überhaupt ausgebrochen
war wo von abzug geredet worden ist und
wo man dann festgestellt dass eigentlich
nur streitkräfte verlegt worden sind und
das gleiche ist das was ich jetzt wieder
erwartet
putin hat ja am 21 februar abends die
beiden regionen buch hans kommt dann
jetzt anerkannt aus russischer sicht
völkerrechtswidrig anerkannt und ich
glaube dass er jetzt versuchen möchte
dass er erst mal diese region komplett
zu 100 prozent in seiner hand
beziehungsweise die hand der
separatisten bekommt und wenn das
gelungen sein sollte muss man abwarten
was die russen dann tatsächlich vorhaben
vor diesem hintergrund die verhandlungen
gehen ja weiter was glauben sie wie
könnte ende ein verhandlungsergebnis
denn aussehen das kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen es gibt nach meinem dafürhalten
von diesen verhandlungen wurde auch von
den verhandlungs zielen die sowohl die
russische als auch die ukrainische seite
hat sehr unterschiedliche meldungen ich
war vor zehn tagen sehr überrascht davon
als auf einmal seelen ski gesagt haben
sollte der präsident dass er
beispielsweise auf den john bass
komplett verzichten wolle ich halte das
für sehr unwahrscheinlich denn das ist
ukrainisches territorium ukrainisches
gebiet welches nach der budapester
komplett konventionen der charta von
paris zu keine gehört und sowohl die
aktionen der kämpfer als auch der
begonnene krieg im jahr 2014 das sind
völkerrechtswidrige ereignisse und da
sollte man sich nicht so ohne weiteres
von entfernen ich sag das mal ganz
einfach so diese bereiche zu behalten
bei der russischen seite ist die
situation eigentlich noch schwieriger
sie schwieriger aus dem grunde weil
wladimir putin sich dort in eine
situation verrannt hat warum können wir
vielleicht zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
noch mal diskutieren
eine situation verrannt hat aus der
jetzt im augenblick nicht mehr rauskommt
und ich habe noch am 16 toten also im
prinzip fünf tage vor diesem berühmten
einundzwanzigsten oder eine woche vor
dem 24 februar gesagt dass ich ihn so
vernünftig halte dass er diesen krieg
nicht anfängt diese meinung musste ich
öffentlich revidieren es ist die
situation so dass er sich da rein
gerannt hat und er muss irgendwie auch
gesichtswahrend soll wieder rauskommen
und das macht die sache besonders
schwierig sein wenn man moment bei den
verhandlungen und ist es so dass die
ukraine offenbar vom westen erwartet für
den fall dass sie sich zur neutralität
bereit erklären würde sicherheits
garantien abzugeben die usa haben sich
da bereits sehr zögerlich verhalten
außenministerin werbung hat gestern
signalisiert sie könnte sich
sicherheitsgarantien vorstellen wie kann
das aussehen was bedeutet das für
deutschland
also als gehören team macht sich
deutschland eigentlich im augenblick
nicht als garantien möchte sich länder
wie russland die vereinigten staaten von
amerika vielleicht noch groß beteiligung
in frankreich warum sage ich das so
deshalb bei der bei der konvention von
budapest 1994 auch garantie möchte
gegeben das war der zeitpunkt zu dem die
ukraine die bei ihnen befindlichen
sowjetischen alten sowjetischen nuklear
waffen abgegeben hatte und damals hat es
im rahmen dieser budapester konvention
auch entsprechende garantie erklärung
gegeben unter anderem von russland es
muss man sich die frage stellen mit dem
blick 16 jahre zurück 9 18 jahre zurück
welche garantie hat russland denn damals
gegeben die das man jetzt die ukraine
angreifen würde oder vorher die krim
annektiert hat das heißt solche
garantien sind nicht so viel wert was
die lenzkircher präsentieren ski will
ist glaube ich das ja praktisch
westliche staaten als eine art
schutzfunktion schutzmacht haben will
und da sind wir genau in der situation
die vorher da war als man darüber
diskutiert hat auf dem die ukraine der
nato beitreten soll es sind dann nicht
mehr alle nato-staaten sondern nur noch
einige die diese garantien übernehmen
können das wird eine situation sein mit
der funktion sich auch nicht zufrieden
geben wird bleiben wir mal bei der
person von wladimir putin sie sagt mir
eben schon er hatte sich vermutlich
anders vorgestellt
geht man davon aus dass wir mit dem
rücken zur wand steht und fragt sich wie
gefährlich das denn nun eigentlich wird
er hat ja auch nicht atomaren waffen
gedroht trauen sie ihm zu dass er den
nato bündnisfall weiter provoziert und
37 und einsatz von atomwaffen zu dem
nato-bündnis völker hinterher nur dann
provozieren wenn er tatsächlich bei
einem der nato-staaten über die grenzen
geht und dort truppenteile auf diesem
boden sei es nationale beispielsweise in
rumänien oder sei es in polen oder bei
den baltischen staaten angreifen würde
ich glaube dass das signal welches die
nato gesetzt hat solange das nato
territorium nicht angegriffen wird haben
wir auch kein bündnis fall ein sehr
wichtiges signal ist oder ein sehr gutes
signal ist man muss immer im kopf
behalten dass die nato liege seit 1949
existiert deutschland mitglied seit 1955
die nato hat in ihrer gesamten
geschichte noch keinen krieg begonnen
und sie hat auch noch niemanden
angegriffen wir haben einmal den
verteidigungsfall verkündet sagte fünf
verkündet dass wir beim angriff auf die
twin towers im september des jahres 2001
nine eleven so das ist die situation das
ist die situation die wir haben und das
muss gut ging eigentlich mal als faktum
anerkennen das was ich möchte oder was
ich sehe und sogar urteil ist die
tatsache dass putin sich im prinzip eine
eigene welt zusammen gebaut hat warum
kann ich nicht sagen möglicherweise weil
er die falschen berater hat oder
möglicherweise weil er gegenüber seinen
beratern so viel angst und schrecken
verbreitet dass diese nicht merkt sich
nicht mehr trauen die wahrheit zu sagen
das ist glaube ich eines der probleme
ich bin fest von überzeugt dass putin
einseitigsten krieg angefangen hat davon
ausgegangen ist dass er das ganze in 45
tagen erledigt haben würde dass die
ukrainische bevölkerung mit russischen
fähnchen am straßenrand stehen würde um
die russen freundlich willkommen zu
heißen und da hat er sich völlig
verkalkuliert
möglicherweise aufgrund von geheimdienst
ergebnissen seines geheimdienstes
möglicherweise aufgrund von falscher
beratung oder beides aber wenn wir jetzt
bei den punkt bleiben dass er vielleicht
seine berater sich wirklich aus angst
nicht trauen die wahrheit zu sagen
englische und amerikanische
geheimdienste gehen ja auch zu teilen
von aus immer mein ist das wirklich
vorstellbar wladimir putin der ja nun
auch im servicefall jede menge
informationsquelle selber nutzen kann
kann es wirklich sein dass ein mann die
linie putin nicht darüber orientiert ist
dass sein feldzug sag ich jetzt mal
nicht so läuft wie er sich das
vorgestellt hatte also ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass wladimir putin
sich zu hause an seinen computer sitzt
im internet forschung geht über
britische meldungen amerikanische
meldungen deutsche meldung die ihm dann
möglicherweise die wahrheit wird
zumindest einen teil der wahrheit über
diesen krieg über diese aussage zu
berichten würden sondern er nutzt seine
berater und diese berater haben
offensichtlich falsch beraten wir
sollten darüber vielleicht auch mal ein
bisschen nachdenken wenn spitzen in der
politik um sich herum ich sag das mal
eine atmosphäre der angst erzeugen dann
leidet darunter die qualität der
beratung erste aussage zweite aussage
egal ob in der wirtschaft egal ob in der
politik egal ob wladimir putin sie
müssen sich ihre berater so aussuchen
das ist charakterlich stark und will
starke personen sind die auch bereit
sind ein risiko einzugehen wenn man
einen präsidenten ein minister- oder
sonst irgend jemand mit der nase auf die
werkstücke zu arbeiten hat letztes
wochenende beim nato gesetzter
überraschung gesorgt und hat die worte
aus dieser mann kann nicht an der macht
bleiben er ist dafür sehr kritisiert
worden hat sich aber später auch
erweitertes zurückzunehmen kann dieser
mann an der macht bleiben
ich wüsste nicht wie putin aus der macht
herausgenommen werden soll es gibt ja
etliche leute die reden darüber dass man
beispielsweise in russland einen graf
schenk von stauffenberg braucht für ein
attentat oder dergleichen wir das für
mich keine kalkulatorische größe
schlicht und einfach formuliert es kann
sein dass es in russland ich sag das mal
vorsichtig aus seiner wahlen gehen auch
andere widerstands oder
oppositionsbewegungen gibt es kann auch
sein dass aus seinem näheren zirkel
militärgeheimdienst oder dergleichen
mehr darüber nachgedacht wird ob der
mann noch richtig entscheiden kann und
richtig denken kann dann müsste man in
russland die konsequenzen ziehen das
kann man nicht von außen steuern und
sollte man auch nicht versuchen von
außen zu beeinflussen weil das der
falsche weg wäre das wäre möglicherweise
eine anführungszeichen leichte
anführungszeichen lösung aber die dann
von innen kommen muss es gibt einen
interessanten teil die nicht zur zeit
sehr sorgfältig beobachten allerdings
noch mit sehr geringen oder wenigen
ergebnissen das ist dieses komitee der
russisch mutter die sich schon mal
gemeldet haben beim tschetschenienkrieg
und auf die regierung damals auch putin
beim zweiten tschetschenienkrieg
einfluss genommen haben das heißt wenn
deren söhne oder väter oder männer oder
der gleich mehr nach hause kommen und
tod sind also ihre leichen nach hause
kommen dass die dann möglicherweise
anfangen sich zu formieren um mehr
widerstand zu leisten
und ich glaube da hat putin eine
erhebliche scheu vor weil dieses komitee
auch in russland selber relativ große
sympathien genießt und wer dagegen die
hart vorgeht wie gegen andere
demonstranten dann könnte das
möglicherweise zu gegenreaktionen führen
aber das ist alles viel gewinn fiel aber
und viel hätte von daher kalkulatorische
baum blick keine aussage viele mir
darüber nachgedacht was ihn stoppen
könnte einige haben ja gehofft dass die
russischen oligarchen die vielleicht
verprellt sein könnten weil ihre
besitztümer eingefroren werden und sie
das fermi nannte leben im ausland nicht
mehr leben können oder dass sie offenbar
irgendwie in den letzten jahren heftig
genossen haben viele haben gedacht so
leicht gibt es doch mehr demonstrationen
und das volk reagiert sehen sie da noch
irgendwelche chancen dass davon
irgendeiner form von innen aus russland
heraus noch weitere gegenwehr kommt also
bei den oligarchen bin ich sehr
vorsichtig war ja die masse der
oligarchischen letztendlich durch die
gunst putins das geld erworben hat und
das geld bekommen hat mit dem sie dann
gut und komfortabel im ausland leben
konnten und von daher sicherlich der
überwiegende teil der oligarchischen
eine gewisse abhängigkeit zwischen putin
und das macht sowas dann ganz besonders
schwierig weil putin sich natürlich auch
entsprechend zur wehr setzen kann und
wir wissen dass es oligarchen gegeben
hat vorverkauf ski ist ein wunderbares
beispiel dafür wie von putin auf
brutalste art und weise entmachtet
worden sind die sahen vor gericht
gestellt worden sind verurteilt worden
sind mittlerweile kolakowski im ausland
lebt aber von denen das zu erwarten dass
sie diesen weg gehen oder das zu
kalkulieren leader ist eine durchaus
schwierige aufgabe es muss von innen
heraus kommen ein abramowitsch stellt
sich dann möglicherweise auf die seite
der ukraine schlecht ist für putin kein
gesprächspartner mehr der hat praktisch
damit seine kunst und seine gnade
verloren und wird auch in russland wenn
alles zu ende sein sollte irgendwann
bald keinen auf keinen grünen zweig
wirkungen dann ist ja fast die ganze
welt überrascht worden von diesem
angriffskrieg den er da angezettelt hat
in der ukraine waren sie davon auch
überraschend was würden sie denken hat
die deutsche außenpolitik versorgen in
den letzten jahren
also vor dem angriff silber war ich
überrascht ich sagte ja vorhin schon mal
ich habe am 16.2 noch gesagt der mann
hat noch so viel rest vernunft dass er
das nicht macht und musste das dann am
21 als er die berühmte rede gehalten hat
als er mit seinen mit seinem
führungskreis zusammen war und dann
anschließend die anerkennung der der
beiden regionen johansson jetzt
unterschrieben hat musste ich das
korrigieren zu dem zeitpunkt wussten wir
noch nicht wann der krieg beginnen würde
das war dann drei tage später am 24
das hat mich schon mächtig überrascht
weil ich nicht gedacht hätte dass
irgendjemand in der welt ein solches
risiko eingeht auf diese art und weise
einen größeren konflikt und dann auch
noch gerade noch in europa loszutreten
aber offensichtlich war er dazu bereit
aber jetzt zu politik und seiner person
silbern es gibt diese berühmte rede die
im september des jahres 2001 im
deutschen bundestag gehalten und dabei
anderthalb jahre gewählter präsident
russlands diese rede ist in deutschen
medien die rede ist in der
öffentlichkeit in der presse von ups
worten von politikern sehr stark und
positiv gewürdigt worden wenn man sich
die ganze rede durchliest dann stellt
man fest dabei dass er einen absatz
erinnert wo er sagt ostern wird
gezwungen sinngemäß russland wird
gezwungen entscheidungen auszuführen die
andere gefällt haben und wo russland
nicht am entscheidungsprozess beteiligt
waren aber diesen satz oder diesen
absatz hat man geflissentlich überhört
weil er in die anderen anderen teil der
rede nicht reinpasst so will man dann
weiter guckt und man schaut auf die
jahre 2004 2006 das war die orangenen
revolution in der ukraine
geschenke und timoschenko die eigentlich
aus präsident und ministerpräsident ein
tolles gespann hätten geben können wenn
sie sich nicht gegenseitig zerstritten
hätten es war eine situation wo putin
versucht hat von außen auf die ukraine
auch einfluss zu nehmen so dann kommt
2008 der georgien-krieg und bei dem
georgien krieg ist eine interessante
feststellung zu beobachten die ersten
haben das vorher in die
nachrichtendienstlichen
informationskanäle eingespeist etwa drei
wochen vorher dass die 58 das 58 dekor
nach einer übung einsatzbereit in
nordossetien liegt und die sind sofort
als der krieg begonnen hat in georgien
südossetien einmarschiert haben das
annektiert haben das besetzt bis heute
nicht wieder raus gegeben genauso wie
abchasien das heißt er wird
scheibchenweise von ländern werden
bestimmte teile abgestellt abgeschnitten
die werden dann völkerrechtlich nicht
anerkannt aber sie werden von putin
anerkannt und das ist das gleiche
verfahren was wir jetzt mit lukas und
jetzt erlebt haben ist also nichts neues
da muss man sich die frage stellen wie
sind diese signale aufgenommen worden
ich war einige wochen nach dem georgien
krieg in den drei baltischen staaten zur
dienst auf sich in meinem
verantwortungsbereich
und bin bei einer pressekonferenz
gefragt worden von den journalisten dort
er general wie denken sie darüber dass
der damalige präsident mit
gesagt hat dass russland das recht habe
russischsprachige bürger auf dem
territorium anderer länder zu schützen
die antwort sehr spontan gegeben von mir
ohne große rechtsberater war einfach die
antwort das ist völkerrechtswidrig
zu treffende antwort was mich dann sehr
berührt hat hinterher war die tatsache
dass ich mir mit dem damaligen der
deutsche nato-general mit dem damaligen
präsidenten von russland drei tage lang
eine diskussion geliefert habe über
interfax und as auf das nun richtig ist
was ich gesagt habe oder richtig ist das
was der präsident gesagt hat medwedew
gesagt hat die antwort ist eindeutig was
mich noch mehr betroffen gemacht hat ist
die tatsache dass dieses zwiegespräch
ich denn das war sie zwischen dem
russischen präsidenten und dem
nato-general weder in der nato noch in
der europäischen union noch von der
bundesrepublik deutschland zur kenntnis
genommen worden ist aber wer hat etwas
verschlafen muss man sich doch fragen
also ich meine wenn es zum beispiel so
ist dass sie das damals auch schon
gesehen haben wie ist da die
aufgabenteilung müssen dann nicht auch
es wird jetzt vielleicht sehr naiv an
mir gefragt aber ich frage mich das
jetzt wirklich wenn man diese
beobachtung macht wie laufen da die wege
zu den regierungen der jeweiligen länder
gibt es da war man wird darüber
gesprochen oder wurde das zur seite
gewischt weil vermeintlich andere themen
wichtiger war ja also ich sagte ja
gerade dass die ersten drei wochen vor
dem georgienkrieg bereits informationen
eingestellt hatten das 58 deko das ist
jetzt der ukraine auch eingesetzt nur
mal ganz am rande in den übungsräumen
verblieben war das ist nicht verständnis
genommen worden eindeutig formuliert das
ist nicht zur kenntnis genommen worden
wahrscheinlich hat man gedacht die
ersten haben angst oder sorge oder sonst
irgendwelche dinge mehr und ich weiß
dass von dieser dreitägigen diskussion
mit medwedew beispielsweise die
botschaften in estland tallinn und in
lettland riga an das auswärtige amt
berichtet haben ich weiß aber nicht was
das auswärtige amt mit diesen berichten
gemacht hat von daher in dieser
situation
sag ich mal ganz vorsichtig hätte man
signale empfangen können wenn man sie
denn hätte empfangen wollen und dann kam
halt die situation die wir erlebt haben
geschichte wiederholt sich nicht sagt
man immer dass wir erlebt haben dass
unmittelbar nach den olympischen
winterspielen in sotschi die annexion
der krim und der krieg in bonn begann so
geschichte wiederholt sich nicht jetzt
vergleichen die situation mal mit der
heutigen situation über jetzt haben auch
da war es nur einen tag 21 februar wo
die berühmte konferenz war und die rede
von punkte und dergleichen mehr um fünf
tage später begann der krieg das heißt
sollte darauf vorbereitet sein können es
gibt erkenntnisse ob die richtig sind
oder falsch kann man schlecht beurteilen
dass putin unter anderem zur eröffnung
der olympischen spiele gefahren ist und
mit ihm über dieses thema zu sprechen
und chipping hat ihm offensichtlich
gesagt bitte nicht während olympische
spiele also hat er gewartet bis die zu
ende waren aber auch darüber gab es
spekulationen dass man gesagt hat wenn
etwas kommt danach
die aussage ist richtig aber man hat es
offensichtlich dann auch noch nicht
wieder richtig ernst genommen das ist
der entscheidende punkt mit dabei lassen
das heißt ich sage wenn ich noch einen
satz sagen darf ich sage es hat in der
zeit von amtsantritt von putin bis 2022
also jetzt zeichen um signale gegeben
dass putin sich in die enge getrieben
fühlte das poken b der auffassung war
dass die ukraine mit zu russland gehört
richtig oder falsch völkerrechtlich
garantiert falsch ob aus der geschichte
heraus falsch mache ich mal fragezeichen
dran wobei das geschichtsbild was putin
beispielsweise am 21 februar oder auch
im jahr 2009 10 bereits vermittelt hat
ich hätte weiter gesagt
geschichtsklitterung schlimmer geht es
nicht dann lassen sie uns noch mal kurz
auf die nato schauen weil am ende muss
man ja fast sagen auch wenn es sich sehr
seltsam anhört die nato ist weiter denn
je ein bündnis das nicht wirklich in der
berichterstattung mal eine große rolle
gespielt hat deshalb einmal einfinden
dass das wirklich sehr sehr beachtet es
in der welt wo viele mitglieder seien
wollen dies wahrscheinlich so schnell
nicht schaffen könnte man sagen dass
dieser krieg die nato einsatz
also einer der nebeneffekte die putin
mit seinem krieg und mit seinem
vorgängigen die ukraine erreicht hat ist
sicherlich die einigkeit der
europäischen union und die einigkeit der
nato wobei die lato meinen augen immer
ein wichtiges bündnis gewesen ist das
mag zum teil von politikern oder medien
anders gesehen worden sein aber ein
blick auf die sicherheit immer wichtig
und das möchte ich alle beispiel
festmachen ich habe miterlebt ich habe
miterlebt wie die polen die tschechei
und die ungarn mitglieder gewonnen sind
in der nato 1999 und ich habe miterlebt
wie im jahr 2004 märz die baltische
staaten die slowakei rumänien und
bulgarien in die nato aufgenommen worden
sind und ich weiß dass diese länder sich
damals alle sehr gefreut haben war
damals in polen und ich habe in meinem
hauptquartier damals die fahnen der
baltische staaten hochgezogen anfang
märz des jahres
2004 und die balken waren froh dass sie
praktisch von einer ich sage mal
katzentisch volle dann eine richtige
rolle rein gebracht worden sind und die
gleiche aussage galt für die anderen
alle länder hatten ein interesse von
polen angefangen bis zu rumänien
bulgarien sie wollten unter dem
sicherheitsschirm der nato schlüpfen
weil sie aus den erfahrungen
ich sag das mal ganz bewusst in der
nachkriegszeit nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg und in zeiten des warschauer
paktes sich vor dem großen bruder
gefürchteter zitiere einen ehemaligen
nva offizier der rams sie müssen zur
kenntnis nehmen 1987 sie müssen zur
kenntnis nehmen sie haben freunde die
kann man sich aussuchen wir haben
brüderle hat man
nun steckt der westen ja wenn man auf
diesen krieg schaut dann einen
zusätzlichen dilemma nämlich die
tatsache dass sie extrem abhängig sind
nach wie vor und das wird sich so
schnell vermutlich nicht ändern von
russischen gas und haben sie das bei der
nato auf dem schirm gehabt da diesmal
und gibt es da ein paar gedanken es geht
in die richtung die sind aber hier
abhängig also ist das etwas was auch bei
der nato diskutiert wurde oder ist es
nur etwas was wo politik gedacht hat
naja wird nichts passieren
und jetzt stehen wir da und wissen nicht
was er machen soll also ich würde sagen
dass dieses thema ich sag mal
energieversorgung energiesicherheit
weniger bei der nato als mehr weiter
europäischen union und vor allen dingen
von unseren auswärtigen mitgliedern der
europäischen union diskutiert worden ist
also die baltischen staaten polen und
andere haben darauf hingewiesen dass
eine solche abhängigkeit
keinen unterwegs ist sie erlauben mir
dass ich vielleicht mal ein paar
jahrzehnte zurück geben
72 73 hatten wir die erste ölkrise ich
konnte mit meiner familie in der nähe
von darmstadt auf der autobahn spazieren
gehen damals hat es einen bundeskanzler
gegeben helmut schmidt der nach diesem
ereignis gesagt haben wir müssen unsere
energieversorgung diversifizieren wir
dürfen von keinem land mehr abhängig
sein als 30 prozent wie anders damals in
deutschland umgestellt nur wir haben sie
in den letzten 20 jahren wieder
umgestellt und das ist der fehler
gewesen diesen blick darauf zu haben wie
viel kann ich mir als importe von einem
land erlauben um nicht von diesem land
abhängig zu sein ist meine ich mit blick
auf eine vernünftige außenpolitik ein
zwingender weg der gegangen werden muss
und wenn dieser weg nicht eingehalten
wird das sieht man jetzt dann kommt man
in einer situation die einen dann
komplett abhängig macht wobei sich jetzt
gedanken darüber machen muss auf gegen
bezahlung in rubel oder nichtbezahlung
hobel und dergleichen mehr wie man jetzt
mit der energieversorgung land lang
kommt viele leute denken dabei zunächst
mal an sich an die heizung die sie zu
aussagen und dergleichen mehr das ist
nicht das problem ich glaube das größere
problem liegt darin dass die wirtschaft
die energie brauchen ihre
produktionsprozesse in betrieb zu halten
denn wenn die zerbrechen wenn die kaputt
gehen wenn möglicherweise daraus auch
technische folgeschäden entstehen dann
wird es für die deutsche wirtschaft
schwierig und wir leben vom export das
muss man deutlich sagen kommen wir
abschließend zu dem so genannten begriff
der zeitenwende der gerne aller mund ist
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat in dem
zusammenhang jetzt auch verkündet dass
es 100 milliarden sondervermögen geben
soll für die bundeswehr in welchem
zustand würden sie sagen ist die
bundeswehr im moment in deutschland und
was bringt auf die einkaufsliste die
bundeswehr ist im jahre 2000 helfen zum
teil auch schon vorher durch
entscheidungen gefällt worden sind 2010
2011 wirklich runtergefahren worden weil
sie nach dem politischen entscheidungen
sich zu 100 prozent auf stabilisierungs
und auslandseinsätze konzentrieren
sollte das bedeutet dass sie alle für
solche einsätze eine erhebliche
vorbereitungszeit größenordnung halbes
jahr kann auch sogar noch mehr sein und
auch diese zeitachse kann man sich dann
entsprechend material von anderen
ausleihen zusammensuchen und dergleichen
dinge mehr es ist eine weitere
entscheidung jahres 2011 gefällt worden
nämlich sich nur noch auf diese
auslandseinsätze zu konzentrieren und
auf die bevorratung von munition und
ersatzteilen auf die bevorratung von
munition und ersatzteilen zu verzichten
so das war eine entscheidung die
vollkommen falsch der mann hätte sich
damit aus rechnen können dass nach drei
oder vier jahren die bundeswehr dann
nicht mehr einsatzbereit ist man geht
irgendwann ans regal will sich in der
sache rausholen es ist keins mehr da
dann geht man zur industrie und fragt
hast du noch und dann sagt hinein haben
wir vor vier jahren die produktion
eingestellt haben wir nicht mehr und
damit liegt die bundeswehr die wir das
2014 erlebt haben am boden von daher um
die streitkräfte einsatzbereit zu machen
ist dieses geld notwendig dazu kommt
auch dass wir viel altes gerät haben ich
denke an den schweren
transporthubschrauber ich denke an den
tornado ich denke aber auch an schiffe
die aus dem dienst gestellt worden sind
die fregatte 122 jahren viel altes
material und dieses material muss
ersetzt werden entweder man hat
streitkräfte die sind einsatzbereit oder
wann hat ein operetten haben wir eine
operetten armee brauchen wir nicht das
haben die ereignisse gezogen wir keine
gezeigt von daher spielt diese was kann
es dass scholz zeitenwende gesagt hat
dieser frage eine wichtige rolle jetzt
kommt es darauf an wie diese 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr eingesetzt
werden wie sie in scheiben geschnitten
werden über die nächsten jahre wie
zusammengeführt werden mit dem ohnehin
invest anteil des
verteidigungshaushaltes und ich hoffe
dass dem generalinspekteur aus den
planungsverantwortlichen das so gelingt
was wir die bundeswehr tatsächlich sagt
man innerhalb der nächsten zehn jahre
acht jahre so auf die beine kriegen dass
sie einsatzfähig ist und ihren auftrag
sowohl im rahmen der bündnisverteidigung
als auch im rahmen der
landesverteidigung gefühlen kann es
früher hatten wir allerdings auch die
wehrpflicht da können wir unter diesen
vorzeichen die jetzt gesetzt werden
überhaupt dabei bleiben dass wir keine
werten haben
also die derzeitige entscheidungslage
sieht vor dass die bundeswehr von bis zu
185 1000 leuten personalmäßig aufsager
mal 200 3000 soldaten aufwachsen sollen
ich rede ungerne von der wehrpflicht
wenn man diese wehrpflicht nicht
unabhängig von anderen dingen sehen darf
sondern ich rede davon was alle welt
kramp-karrenbauer vor einigen jahren
bereits gesagt da von einer allgemeinen
dienstpflicht
ich stelle aber fest wenn ich mit
politikern über die allgemeine
dienstpflicht rede dass viele politiker
von vornherein sein pflichtdienst
vollmer lich wenn die bundeswehr auf
203.000 soldaten aufwachsen soll und ich
glaube dass es mit blick auf die
bedeutung deutschlands die größe
deutschlands die bevölkerung
deutschlands und das bild deutschlands
vielleicht sogar noch zweckmäßig wäre
vielleicht auch mal ein paar zehntausend
noch mehr nachzudenken dann kann ich nur
sagen dann kann ich nur sagen dann muss
man die bereitschaft dazu haben und dann
muss man auch über eine allgemeine
dienstpflicht nachdenken ich darf noch
ein paar andere punkte in dem
zusammenhang an denn wir haben probleme
mit der pflege was das personal angeht
wir haben früher zivildienstleistenden
pflegedienst gehabt wir haben probleme
mit den feuerwehren insbesondere
freiwilligen voller wir haben früher
zivildienstleistende bei feuerwehren
geraten die wusste sich verpflichten wir
haben probleme mit dem personal der
rettungsdienste auch da könnte auf
diesem wege einer allgemeinen
dienstpflicht möglicherweise eine lösung
gefunden werden und ich möchte erinnern
an john f kennedy der mal gesagt hat
denke nicht darüber nach was dein land
für dich tun kann denke darüber nach was
du für dein land tun kannst nicht glaube
dann wäre das vielleicht ein ganz
vernünftiger ansatz der zumindest auch
gesellschaftlich oder in der politik
sehr sorgfältig geprüft und diskutiert
werden müsste abschließend nochmals ein
begriff der zeiten werden der in sachen
umdenken wir haben uns ja jahrzehntelang
fast schon verträumt dem slogan
hingegeben frieden schaffen ohne waffen
jetzt ist uns in den letzten wochen doch
sehr klar geworden dass es vielleicht
nicht verkehrt ist auch wehrhaft zu sein
was würden sie sagen weder
gesellschaftlich laut genug debattiert
muss man da die bevölkerung nicht
mitnehmen also wir haben diese debatte
haben wir eigentlich nicht jetzt den
letzten jahren sondern die haben wir
über jahrzehnte versäumt
also es den umschwung gegeben hat mit
der friedensbewegung etwa ende der 70er
anfang der 80er jahre in verbindung mit
dem nato-doppelbeschluss
für den ja einer der initiatoren helmut
schmidt war also ein deutscher kanzler
der dann in der in seiner eigenen partei
über diesen doppelbeschluss gefallen ist
und dann irgendwann aufgrund des
doppelbeschluss auch durch helmut kohl
abgelöst worden ist wir hatten damals
diese diskussion aufnehmen müsste man
hätte damals ich sage dass wir
vorsichtig die bundeswehr nicht eine
bestimmte ecke stellen dürfen ich habe
früher immer gesagt die bundeswehr ist
die älteste friedensbewegung die beiden
deutschland haben denn wir sind
geschaffen und gegründet worden um den
frieden in europa und in deutschland das
ist unser erster auftrag und das ist
auch nach wie vor in das soll auch so
bleiben ich habe selber das erlebnis
gehabt bei der friedensbewegung 80 81
als junger hauptmann auf dem podium zu
sitzen und doppelbeschluss der
eigentlich durch die politik hätte
verteidigt werden müssten dann gegenüber
diskutieren oder ein auditorium war der
gleichen verteidigen zu dürfen oder zu
müssen kann man sehen wie man will was
ich damals auch gerne getan habe und
viele meiner kameraden auch weil wir im
prinzip die botschaft da gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit waren mit blick auf diese
politik aber diese politik hätte
vertreten werden müssen durch politiker
was ja auch sagen ich war vorsichtig
zumindest in einer größeren partei
damals auch nicht mehr der fall war
bewaffnete demokratie ist meine ich ein
gutes man sorgfältig nachdenken sollte
und auch sorgfältig reden und
diskutieren sollte und ich nehme die
schweiz als beispiel die schweiz hat
seit 350 jahren kein krieg mehr geführt
sie ist nach wie vor gut bewaffneten gut
ausgerüstet und wenn man von deutschland
in die schweiz reinfährt dann sieht man
straßen befestigung die wir auch mal
gehabt haben an der deutschen grenze
diesen aber nicht mehr gibt bei uns also
bei uns ist wirklich anfang der 90er
jahre der ewige friede ausgebrochen ich
zitiere volker rühe wir sind nur noch
von freunden umzingelt aber niemand kann
garantieren dass dieses in zwei jahren
drei jahren fünf jahren noch so ist und
wir haben mal bei konzeptionen der
bundeswehr von zehn jahren vorwarnzeit
gesprochen jetzt gucken wir mal zurück
die ukraine auf die aktuelle situation
die ersten truppenteile die sich
richtung ukraine bewegt haben zum teil
aus sibirien aus nowosibirsk heraus sind
marschiert im februar des jahres
das heißt seit einem jahr seit einem
jahr sind die indikatoren da und wenn da
eine solche situation passiert wie sie
jetzt passiert ist mit der ukraine dann
kann man von einer vorwarnzeit von zehn
jahren mit sicherheit nicht mehr reden
das heißt in dem fall müssen dann auch
bestimmte rahmenbedingungen zwangsläufig
anders gestaltet werden damit sie
innerhalb eines jahres oder einer
notwendigerweise noch kurzer zeit
einsatzbereit streik gestern über das
was es braucht für den frieden wären wir
vermutlich nach dem nächsten monate oder
auch die nächsten jahre diskutieren ich
denke er würde es auch viele
gegenpositionen geben zu ihrer wir aber
jetzt hat deshalb ich glaube ich gar
nicht mehr rein bringen können ich danke
ihnen für das gespräch
[Musik]